I think there's a massive war on  masculinity right now but I think it's a  war which has been going on for a very  long time I mean you only need to look  at like media headlines for example they  say if a man wants to be fit and strong  he's suddenly right wing they talk about  Jim Bros being dumb and all this stuff  you're also now encouraging men to cry  and to do all these emotional things I  think they're trying to make women more  masculine and make men more feminine but  it's so toxic if a man is brave and  strong suddenly that's toxic masculinity  if a man wants to provide for his family  that's toxic masculinity when it comes  to equality and wanting quotas you never  hear anything about plumbers Builders  you don't want more female Builders show